well just days before the credit card
controversy mayor Adams brushed off his
critics while touting himself and his
diverse leadership
team have you ever seen this much
chocolate leading the city of New
York and then go down the line look look
who's here this is representative of the
city that's why people are hating on
me you trying to figure
out why they're hating on me they hating
on me because those are how many you go
to
church ma'am this is a Matthew 21 and 12
moment Jesus walked in the temple he saw
them doing wrong in the temple he did
what he turned the table over I went to
City Hall to turn the table over okay
that is expensive you kidding me right
now I have a heart for unaccompanied
minor children who cross our border I do
and families who are destitute I also
have a heart for the taxpayer the single
mom the single dad the struggling family
who doesn't get benefits who are
American citizens all right so we're
going to unpack it I'll start there
we'll do it in chronological order that
you laid it out um this is more than
about who's not getting what this is
about who we are
becoming we we cannot hate ourselves as
American
citizens and then love everybody else
who potentially didn't even the vast
majority didn't come here legally like
that that's not who we can afford to
become our country will change in a way
snapping back will be tough I'm strong
in my faith in a different way perhaps
than mayor
Adams that was so offensive I I tweeted
yesterday because Brandon Johnson the
the city mayor of Chicago did something
very similar to this yesterday he said
that he's not able to do his job and get
to the border and handle all the the
complaints against him with regard to
illegal immigrants and black residents
feeling like they're they're not getting
resources that that the immigrants are
getting here illegally um and he said
well it's because I'm married to a black
wife and I have black children and I'm a
black man and I'm this and I'm that and
that's why I can't get it done it is
being black the excuse now for not
understanding how to run your
city black white hispanic people of
every ilk do their jobs every day
irrespective of our hair texture and
skin color we don't get pass with a
microphone in our hands to say well I'm
going to be bad at it because I'm black
like what is this road we're going down
lane two we don't want to be that either
yeah I I don't understand it Emily you
know yesterday I mentioned the plight of
a single mom who doesn't have a shot at
the American Dream works tireless hours
and then sees her money going to someone
else in the form of a credit card and
the responses I got on social media were
startling 100% single mother here who
slept on accounts for 7 years and is so
in debt that I'm swimming in debt this
is my daughter currently another man
said sad thing is she worked two jobs
when she was pregnant and I went to do
her taxes and she owes money now and
that money is going to credit cards for
illegal immigrants I have my single
daughter who's a mother of one
struggling daily 10 responses here all
the same you know the
sacrifices that those parents make that
those moms make that everyone makes to
ensure that their children are safe and
sound and accounted for I can't imagine
having additional sacrifices levied on
top of that by the government that you
entrust with your tax dollars to care
for you and to provide that safe place
and for those saying that's exactly what
the immigrants are coming here for
that's true but that's true true and
unrelated from the concept that people
who live in this city and who pay their
taxes and who came here legally and who
are doing everything they can to provide
for their families have somehow been
quashed to the lowest part of the barrel
as this mayor and these policies Elevate
everyone but them today I was walking to
work every day I'm like this is the new
story that I see on the sidewalks but
the whole point is the multi-layer of
competing chaotic interest that I see on
the streets and today it was a bunch of
homeless people sleeping on the lawn in
Central Park the one that's currently
being reated so it was a safe place for
them because it's inside the fence and
so here you go and people are just
trying to keep the Central Park you know
that that that's supposed to be a place
for kids to enjoy because all the
programs for kids have been slashed the
libraries are closed on Sundays everyone
is just trying to have some type of
peace and education and safety for
themselves $2 billion now going to
illegal immigrant Healthcare what about
all the people I see in line what about
the ones I hear on the phone at the
pharmacy pleading and begging with their
insurance company and the the all all
the things that everyone has here this
and the veteran injury the veteran we're
cutting the veterans budget yeah it's a
finite it's a finite pool of resources
and you know this is the thanks that
people get and what is the return on on
investment you know if if you invest in
this country's Freedom how does this
country pay you back and and the VA is
horribly run all you have to do is
listen to stories of people who are
trying to access care and now that is
being slashed because they can't
incentivize people to stay at the VA
longterm and help the veterans who need
it most and you know those are the ones
who have the wherewithal to go and get
the services the ones who have been
discarded and who are homeless and who
are left on the streets to minger and
mental illness and everything else they
get even fewer resources because there
are fewer shelter beds you know you've
got older New Yorkers who are kicked out
of public housing and some of these
shelters to make room for migrants you
have kids who are now being inserted
into public schools who cannot be
disciplined or kicked out even if they
assault your child because of the ass
backwards laws that we've got in the
city and in the state and in this
country so it's you know and and Harris
made this point early in the show we've
given up on our way of life and we can't
and you have to stop voting people in
who will make these god- awful decisions
for you yeah Steve people are so sick of
it you that that attempted justification
from Adams you hear that the whole time
well actually there sort of bureaucratic
BS well actually it saves money because
we're not doing it's exactly the same to
Emily's point you here in California now
where they've just extended Health Care
to all illegal IM anyone free healthcare
meanwhile working people to your point
you struggling since Obamacare because
they don't get free healthare their
deductibles gone up their C it's just a
nightmare for people trying to do the
right thing and these guys it seems to
me have just completely lost their moral
compass and their Humanity when it comes
to the people who actually pay their
salaries and sex change surgeries don't
forget that illegal immigrant sex change
surgeries in California welcome to 2024
more outnumbered in just a moment hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-host Harris fulman and Kaye
mechineni on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights